so finally the cryptocurrency mind a man
has come to a full halt
India's top lot of graphics cards are
out and Nvidia and AMD graphics card
prices have finally settled down so what
is the best graphics card that you can
buy this Black Friday first of all don't
buy the rx 560 rx 570 or GTX 1050 the
GTX 1050 is the lowest level card of the
10 series and now the 20 series is out
it is really outdated and it really
makes no sense to buy a card that's
outdated and it's the lowest level card
so if you just want an entry-level basic
card then I really recommend that you at
least spring for a GTX 1063 gigabyte
card or an RX 580 or gear by card both
of these cards are great 1080p graphics
cards which will provide you more than
60 frames per second on high level
settings maybe not Ultron all games but
definitely high level for the next three
to five years as for buying right now
both of these cards are very close in
performance but I recommend the Ark's
584 gigabyte card over the GTX 1016
speaking white card base right now the
incentives associated with the RX 584
gigabyte card are much greater for
example right now if you buy an rx 584
gigabyte card then you get two free
games of your choice
both debate cards right now are 108
dollars but with the RX 580 you get to
three games associated with it also
there was action of the rx 584 gigabyte
car that started with 106 dollars with
the same to three games but that is
currently out of stock as a result if
you're just getting into gaming right
now you don't really know how much
you'll do it or just a casual gamer who
wants a good graphics card then I
strongly recommend the rx 584 gigabyte
card and that you aim to get it for 150
dollars or less this Black Friday now if
you want something that just a little
bit better than that I can handle all
current games after all ultra settings
at 60 frames per second at 1080 P then
you want to look at the RX 588 gigabyte
card or the gtx 1066 gigabyte card as of
right now the gtx 1066 by card costs
$200 and the RX 588 gateway card cost
$190 so again the pricing is very
similar and the performance is pretty
much identical
however the gtx 10-6
six Quebec card light comes at one game
which is Monster Hunter but the arts 588
gigabyte card you choose two games of
your choice as a result if you want a
solid today big graphics card for the
future
I really recommend getting two arcs 588
a buy card right now because of the
incentives associated with it and ask
for Black Friday I recommend that you
guys aim to get it for 150 to 180
dollars but something to be careful of
and keep in mind is that price
difference between two arcs 580 or
gigabyte card and rx 588 gigabyte card
face it may be very small and I really
recommend that you spring for the rx 588
gigabyte card Enterprise difference is
less than $30 because you definitely
won't regret that if you have much more
serious about gaming and you want a
powerful graphics card like a handle
1440p gaming or absolutely wrecked 1080p
gaming then the GTX 970 or gtx 1070 TI
is your best bet
both these cards can handle 1440p at 60
frames per second right now but in the
future the 1070 I will last you longer
and as of right now gtx 1070 is
definitely the way to go because the
price difference is so minimal the gtx
1070 cost three hundred and four dollars
and the gtx 1070 i is three hundred and
fifty-five dollars so just fifteen
dollars but a lot more performance so as
a result if you're a more than casual
gamer and would like to have a powerful
card that's not too expensive and i
really recommend getting the gtx 1070 TI
this black friday for 300 to 350 dollars
asks for the gtx 1070 i recommend buying
that card if you can find it for less
than $300 but the price tickets put in
gtx 1070 and gtx 1070 i it's less than
$50 and i really recommend it you just
go for the gtx 1070 TI finally if you're
an enthusiast who wants to do 4k gaming
or triple more in 1080p gaming or alter
by 1440p gaming or any of those gaming
style that extreme then the gtx 1080 is
a perfect card for you Oryx Vega it just
isn't as good when you look at the bang
for the buck factor and right now and
the high level the pictures would leave
clear simply just go with the GTX 280
the GTX 280 is way overpriced like 1200
1300 when it should cost $600 $7 max
and the r-tx cards were very overpriced
from the very beginning and in video
just trying to sell them on the rate
trace of technology however great racing
technology just isn't that good right
now and it makes no sense to go for
those cards now if nvidia took out the
rate trace technology and sold cards
like GTX 2080 and GTX 2074 about similar
prices to what the GTX 1070 and 1080
launched for then that would actually be
quite enticing but as of right now the
architects cards making no sense so for
next week if you want a high level GPU
then GTX 1080 is your best choice and
try to get it for less than $450 which
is actually a really good deal because
that launched the GTX 1080 started at
$700 and one year later when the gtx
980ti came out and dropped to $600 so
you're still saving a lot of money like
about 25% so overall these are the best
cards that I think you should buy for
each graphics card level and these are
the best prices that I think you should
aim for so what do you guys think do you
guys think I'm wrong about any of my
recommendations or is there any other
graphics cards that I forgot like a Mew
Navi or Intel's graphics cards make sure
to comment down below what you guys
think because I do it all my comments
and curious as to what you guys think -
make sure to post your thoughts also if
you guys likes really make sure drop a
like and consider subscribing if you'd
like to see more videos just like this
one
well until next time I'm Hari I'll see
you guys on the next one
[Music]